so nur noch zwei tage bis zum super
wahlsonntag bundestag meck pomm und
berlin berlin wird auch regiert wissen
viele gar nicht von rot rot grün die
haben sich selbst neulich ein
hervorragendes zeugnis ausgestellt für
die letzten fünf jahre warum soll man
sich nicht auch mal selber gut finden so
67 prozent der berliner allerdings sagen
sie seien mit der arbeit ihres senats
eher oder sehr unzufrieden
gleichzeitig stehen die rzb parteien in
den umfragen zusammen bei 55 nach dem
motto ich find wie vor spaß die sollen
unbedingt bleiben wird ist bei wie
politikverdrossenheit seit 1244
generell schon ziemlich verdrossen ob
das rot grüne ob der cdu oder sonst wer
ist ich finde es passiert halt nicht
viel
zeige mir einen zufriedenen berliner und
ich sage dir das ist überhaupt kein
berliner da kommt aus schwaben parallele
zum bund in den umfragen führt die spd
mit spitzenkandidat in franziska
gefallen wir erinnern uns als
familienministerin zurückgetreten wegen
doktorarbeit und abschreiben aber das
muss ja nicht das ende der karriere sein
wer sagt denn dass man immer aus scham
zurücktreten muss man kann sich ja auch
mal verbessern vgh ist populär weil
pragmatisch und volksnah eine frau mit
vielen talenten die gerne anpacken ob
als müll frau als krankenpflegerin oder
als ornithologin ihr glaubt man alles
bis auf den doktortitel hat so aber wie
fällt die bilanz des rot rot grünen
senats aus sagen wir so es war nicht
alles schlecht
25.000 neue kita-plätze zum beispiel ein
günstiges sozialticket für den
öffentlichen nahverkehr und obdachlose
wurden im winter besser untergebracht
immerhin jetzt kurz zu dem was in berlin
nicht so läuft alles andere zum beispiel
die sache mit den mieten ganz aktuelle
studie von den zehn für familien auf
wohnungssuche am wenigsten
erschwinglichen deutschen stadtteilen
liegen sieben in berlin 7 und wissen sie
wer schuld ist das mieten monster nimmt
und alles unseren alltag unsere träume
unserer existenz doch es gibt hoffnung
wir sind fest entschlossen das mieten
monster zu besiegen und wir wissen auch
schon wie berlin braucht den mieten
deckel yeah wir hauen das mieten monster
kaputt mit dem mieten decke so war der
plan bis dann ein gewisses
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat
dürft ihr gar nicht als kleiner bissiger
stadtstaat genau davor hatten vorher
alle experten gewarnt aber hey einfach
mal ausprobieren übermorgen stimmen die
berliner übrigens auch noch über das
volksbegehren deutsche wohnen & co
enteignen ab
konzerne mit mehr als 3000 wohnungen
würden vergesellschaftet damit hätte
berlin zwar keine einzige wohnung mehr
aber 30 milliarden entschädigung weniger
ja mit dem rechnen haben sie es eh nicht
so in der hauptstadt berlin gerade
15.000 wohnungen von bono via und
deutsche wohnen zurückgekauft da saßen
die vertreter des rot rot grünen senats
nahm sich vom immobilienhai über den
tisch ziehen lassen ein top angebot nur
heute
24 milliarden für wohnungen die ihr uns
mal verkauft hat und ich muss bekommt
sein genau diese putzen könnt ihr jetzt
von uns wieder zurückkaufen und zwar für
das fünffache
läuft in berlin wird weiter zu wenig
gebaut unter anderem wegen zu langer
genehmigungs und planungszeiten und auch
andere rot-rot-grüne vorsätze wurden
nicht wirklich umgesetzt zum beispiel
auch das mit dem im großen stil radwege
bauen ja er ist in den letzten fünf
jahren einfach zu wenig passiert es
bleibt also beim täglichen nervenkrieg
radfahrer gegen autofahrer wen siehst du
das verhältnis autofahrer fahrradfahrer
in berlin also ich finde die radfahrer
extrem aggressiv
weil die immer auf ihren recht beharren
verdammte kampfradler beharren kksv
recht auf ihr recht nicht zu sterben zu
viele autos zu wenig platz für alles
andere eines der ganz großen ungelösten
berliner probleme immerhin gibt es seit
der korona krise die so genannten top up
radwege ja einige davon sind zwar schon
wieder verschwunden aber das prinzip ist
nicht schlecht du nimmst den auto ist
einfach eine spur weg und sagte das ist
jetzt ein radweg ist preiswert und
genial warum machen wir nicht alles als
pop up was weiß ich pop up altenheime
zum beispiel oder popup kitas warum
nicht gut fürs immunsystem wenn die
frühe feinstaub kriegen die kleinen
vielleicht sollte man neben berlin
einfach noch ein funktionierendes popup
berlin aufbauen ja das faszinierende an
dieser stadt ist ja egal wer regiert
bestimmte probleme bleiben immer
vielleicht ist da irgendwas im
trinkwasser ihr habt keine ahnung zum
beispiel das elend mit der berliner
verwaltung du wartest in berlin ewig auf
deinen termin deswegen hat man jetzt das
ist kein spaß ausdrücklich verkündet das
am sonntag auch mit abgelaufenen
personalausweis gewählt werden darf ja
sie lachen aber dahinter verbergen sich
schicksale
dennis knossalla versucht online einen
termin beim bürgeramt berlin neukölln zu
buchen sein personalausweis läuft
nächste woche ab
schon im oktober
2024 kein problem
in berlin kann ich auch einfach als
sogenannter ein notfall kunde aufs amt
gehen ein bisschen warten
[Musik]
juni
drei wochen später knossalla hat seinen
gut dotierten job in einer berliner bank
gekündigt und wohnt jetzt mit seiner
frau stephanie hier
es ging nicht anders ich bin jetzt
vorübergehend arbeitslos weil ich hier
nicht weg kann bevor die schweine meine
person nicht verlängert haben es aber
kein problem wir haben das haus verkauft
man kann in dieser kapstadt einfach
nicht gleichzeitig vollzeit arbeiten und
zeigen ausweis verlängern es geht
kurz vor weihnachten bekommen die
knossalla sie erstes kind im
wartebereich des bürgeramtes
[Applaus]
im berliner ämtern gibt es wegen
personalmangels aktuell 250.000
unerledigte termine die wenigen
sachbearbeiter kriegt man nur sehr
selten zu gesicht
[Musik]
bis spätestens ende 2022 sollen alle
berliner ämter digitalisiert werden
dieser termin ist jetzt schon geplatzt
[Musik]
dennis knossalla lebt immer noch in
bürgerabend neukölln wir werden ihn nie
vergessen
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich